i'm a massive fan you have been a huge
huge influence
on where i've got to now and
i think it wouldn't be too extreme to
say that you don't understand
the magnitude of the impact that you've
had on people
because you can't see how the impact
you've had on people has had their
impact on others
you are degrees of separation removed
from an undeniably better world as far
as i can see it yes and so is everyone
else
yeah i mean you can be woken up to that
and then i can tell you something about
that because i do understand it to some
degree
i think because people constantly
approach me
and i see because i watch but i can tell
you as well that there is nothing that's
that's it's so gratifying
that it's almost too much you know and
it's a funny thing because you could say
well what if you could have everything
you wanted
then the next question is do you really
think you could stand that
and so you know i'm in this unbelievably
fortunate circumstance
where people tell
me about
the steps they've taken to make
their lives better
in wonderment
and they allow me to see that
and it's it's very intimate you know and
it's it's
stunning i'm walking with a friend of
mine
quite regularly and he's a tough guy man
he he's worked with delinquents his
whole life so
he's he's like a social worker superhero
uh very physically tough person and a
very masculine
male but a social worker and very caring
and he's been very helpful to me and
he's been walking with me every day and
people are stopping me and you know
the other day this guy walked by us on
the street and he was pretty run down
he's probably in his mid 40s and
he's kind of street person looking you
know
and he stopped and he looked at me and
he came over and he said
i love you and i walked away and my
friend said
you sure have a lot of men coming up to
you and saying that they love you
i mean i don't know i just don't know
what to make of it it's so
the behavior is so completely
unusual and you know my wife too she
said she's seen a whole different side
of men
especially since we started touring
because of this happening because
generally when people approach me and
they're not invariably men but they
probably are
70 percent of the time they're very
polite
and and very careful and
she said that's showed her a whole side
of men that she didn't even know existed
and so it's it's
it's something but i do believe that
people
you know it's i do believe
that my experience has been that
there isn't anything that i
guess two things there isn't anything
that's more rewarding than trying to do
things
right all other forms of reward
pale by comparison they're not even in
the same conceptual universe
and there's nothing that's more
adventurous
than telling the truth you have no
idea what will happen to you if you tell
the truth
and so if you're looking for an
adventure a boy
that's an adventure
you've said that sometimes you feel
ashamed because you don't feel worthy of
being
some sort of sage at the head of a
movement of people that are sorting
their lives out
but in the nicest way possible you
don't get to choose if people follow you
we chose you
like as the prototypical 27 year old
directionless guy that stumbled onto
your work
something in you spoke to something in
me you taught me the value of telling
the truth and of being responsible and
of doing what is right not what is easy
it was like um it was like a pebble at
the top of an intellectual awakening
avalanche it was like a like a gateway
drug to integrity
and it's not just me that's got better
the world is undeniably a better place
because of the sort of person that i've
become i'm a better
friend i'm a better son i'm a better
boss i'm a better partner
i've had the fortune of reaching tens of
millions of people on this podcast and
i've given tedx talks and i've improved
the texture of my own daily existence
because of the process that your work
triggered
you do not know the depth of impact that
your work has had
and if the option had been there i
and probably a lot of other people would
have happily taken on our share of your
suffering
over the last year if it would have
somehow helped as a thank you for how
you've helped us
so thank you
it looks to me like you are doing that
from everything you just said
so you know hooray great
that that's exactly how to do it and
and it's a privilege to be uh involved
in
in this and you know god only knows what
the consequences will be
so you know we'll aim high
and work hard and speak carefully
and be appreciative and all of that and
then we'll see what happens
jointly thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy
peace